ashley has come to the beach
to be closer to the little sister she
fears is lost forever
cassie stratton lived on the fourth
floor of the champlain towers south
this is what remains she was on the
phone with her husband and then it was
like
honey the pool's caving in
the pool's sinking in and he's like what
are you talking about and she said
the pool it's sinking in the ground
the ground is shaking everything's
shaking
and then she screamed a death curdling
screen
and the phone hung up and we've never
been able to find her ever again
i got to be realistic
my sister's my sister's dead
they've never experienced anything like
this in florida
building collapses of this nature simply
don't happen here
rescuers faced with an almost
insurmountable challenge
sifting through debris with buckets
they're using microphones to listen for
noise
any hint that someone could still be
alive in this wreck of concrete and
twisted metal
so far the death toll is four most
expect it to rise
far higher with 159 people still
unaccounted for
this was a high-end apartment block on
the atlantic coast
and it was the units facing the beach
and the ocean that were most
devastatingly affected
survivors were mere feet away from utter
tragedy
albert and his family know how lucky
they are
i look to the left and the
unit directly next to us is sheared off
was about half the unit left i looked
directly ahead of us which is where the
elevators are and it's just a hole
we got to the pool area we had to do
another like three foot jump we were
okay
able to make it there um and then
at that point is where i think we all
looked back and
saw the actual damage we had no idea
families of the missing are questioning
whether this tragedy
had been foreshadowed i've been told of
flooding in the building
of construction work and sinkholes but
the mayor says it's not the time for
apportioning blame
do you promise them that someone will be
held accountable for what happened
well i promise that we'll find out what
happened i promise that
absolutely there's no doubt but right
now the task is to get people out of
there safely
the recovery operation here is complex
and it's likely to take
weeks with anger simmering beneath the
surface
the search for answers and
accountability
will stretch far beyond that